by the way Troy Aikman finished third in
the Heisman I think that was Barry
Sanders you're Troy joins us on the
program that's a tough one Troy you know
Barry Sanders is the Heisman winner I
was the Malcolm Perry you were that
mobile and I'll tell you when I got
there to New York Barry Sanders could
not be there for the actual presentation
he had a game in Japan Oklahoma State
was played in Japan and and I asked him
before the day before I said so nobody
knows other than whoever counted the
votes
who won the Heisman Han they said no
nobody knows I said it's interesting and
I walked in and it was Barry Sanders
entire family occupying the auditorium
and I wasn't asked to even bring my mom
and anyway yeah and I tell people one of
my favorite quotes was when Barry
Switzer was talking about facing Barry
Sanders and he said he told his defense
do not hurt Thurman Thomas who was
starting Barry because they were worried
Barry was going to come in as the backup
in Barry Switzer was really concerned
about Barry Sanders he was totally right
I mean and hey an interesting story then
was I was at the Kodak all-america team
before my senior year in Miami and this
guy comes up to me and a buddy who were
sitting there having lunch and he says
hey do you mind if I said I don't have
lunch with you said not at all and he
says I'm not even sure really why I'm
here I said well what do you mean he
goes well I'm just a kick returner I
said well you must be a pretty good one
because they asked you to come be a part
of this you know preseason all-american
team it was Barry Sanders and he went on
and of course won the Heisman Trophy
hadn't had no campaign behind him it was
pretty remarkable and I can tell you we
I saw him in Detroit on Thanksgiving Day
he's the same guy today as he was the
first time I ever met him before he had
ever even done anything at Oklahoma
State he's the most unaffected superstar
I've ever been around
yeah I'm right there with you I always
bring that up about Barry Sanders and
the other person I bring it up about is
Dale Murphy the former Atlanta brave
star these were to quiet humble
superstars
you would never know it if they if you
didn't know who they were you wouldn't
know what they did for a living and they
don't they wouldn't tell you but if you
watched Barry it's you know he didn't
need to say anything he certainly said a
whole lot by just the way he ran and the
fact that he didn't even I don't know if
he knew how great he was cuz I would say
boy look at what you did to that
defensive back he goes yet I should feel
bad about that right yeah and you know
he didn't he certainly didn't want to
talk about it and we played him on
Monday Night Football one year I think
in 1993 or something and and he ran he
traversed the field a couple of times he
wound up that we couldn't tackle him he
finally went out of bounds and gained
about two yards and I was standing on
the sidelines next to Jason Garrett and
I said don't I said that might be the
greatest run I've ever seen well for two
yards for two yards you had the game
with the Cowboys and Rams we'll get the
Cowboys in a moment the reason why the
Rams are not going to the playoffs is
because what well they just first of all
I think that the the struggles that they
had in the offensive line obviously had
had some things to do to derail their
season and some of the issues they had
on the offensive side of the ball I
think they came on just a little bit too
late but the other part of it we had
them back early in the season on
Thursday night at Seattle and they had a
chance you know as a Zuerlein missed
field goal that would have won the game
and had they have won that game the
season looks entirely differently and
you know other than the fact they went
into yesterday's game against the
Cowboys but I will say this that it's
been a disappointing season of course
for them when you go to the Super Bowl
and then most likely they're not going
to make the postseason I still think
they're a really talented team and I
think they're an extremely well coached
team
I've been around Sean McVeigh and he's
as good an offensive mind as as I've
ever been around and that I don't worry
about them I don't I don't worry about
Jared Goff either I believe they'll be
right back in the thick of things next
year yeah but my concern is here's Sean
McVeigh having this realization epiphany
where he goes you know what I don't know
what I was thinking I should have been
running Todd Gurley more
they did this was load management it
felt like Troy and if he'll style I
agree I totally agree and and I don't
know that but I totally agree with you I
think that they have a lot invested in
todd gurley they're on the books for him
at least until 2021 with the new
contract I think they're trying to
manage him he's still you know capable
of being a really good player and he and
he has shown that but I believe last
year based on what happened and how he
wore down and and trying to deal with
the knee and manage that as best they
can I think he had the right approach
and I think Sean one of the things that
they really liked about him they being
the players is that you know he doesn't
come out publicly and and always say the
things that probably should be said with
regards to players or who played well
who didn't play well sometimes I think
players need some of that but I think he
had when he says hey I was an idiot and
that's why Gurley didn't get more more
touches he knows exactly what he's doing
with his personnel and there's there's a
reason behind everything Sean McVeigh
does Troy Aikman the Hall of Famer he'll
be on the call with Joe Buck Dallas in
Philadelphia next Sunday for the NFC
East title all right explain to me where
this Cowboys team has been all season
long the one we saw yesterday well so
it's been a hard day they've been in an
enigma I mean it's just been hard to
figure this team out because when you
prepare if you haven't seen them and
you're just preparing for one particular
game or if you're looking at their
numbers you'd say well there's how's
this team six and seven and it is
difficult to figure out you you can't
put your finger really on any one
particular thing I guess with the
exception of special teams and the
special teams has not been very good all
season long but there's been games New
England being one orleans being one
where the defense came out and played
exceptionally well there's been other
games like Chicago where the defense is
struggled and there's been other times
when the offenses has failed to get it
done or they put up a lot of yards but
then the missed field goes I know the
two weeks against Buffalo and
Thanksgiving Chicago if they simply made
field goals it would be an entirely
different game at least going into the
fourth quarter instead you miss a couple
field goals and then they score a
touchdown all of a sudden you find
yourself in a huge deficit you know in
the second half
and the game plan changes to some degree
and so it's been a it's been a
head-scratcher
but I'd at yesterday Journal broadcasts
and people might laugh at this if
they're critics of the Cowboys and I
certainly could understand it but
they're capable of playing like they did
yesterday and that is a good Rams team
and and I don't think there's a team in
the NFC that that wants to face the
Cowboys if they're playing as well as
they're capable of playing and maybe
yeah you can say that about anybody but
there's very few teams in this league
Dan that are really good on both sides
of the ball or at least capable of being
great on both sides of the ball and this
is one of those teams they just haven't
played very well until yesterday
yesterday was obviously their their best
performance against a good football team
and and who knows I mean they as crazy
as it sounds what I've seen of
Philadelphia the last two weeks even
though they've won has not looked very
good
I mean it's looked really bad they beat
bad football teams late in games it's
going to determine everything next week
of course then Philadelphia if they win
they've got to go win in the final game
of the season but if Dallas gets in
there they're capable if they hit it at
the right time doing some damage and who
knows where it might take them but it
feels like Jerry Jones is still looking
at Jason Garrard saying if you don't get
to the NFC title game well I that was
the expectation coming into this season
was that for some reason I don't know I
don't think Jerry Jones ever said that
Jason had to get the championship game
but but he said we should be better so
better since they went to the divisional
game last year meant to everyone else
well they must make it then to the NFC
Championship game the way the season is
gone it's been tough it's been tough on
Jason he's obviously a friend of mine
I've known him for 30 years is it time
to have another voice in that locker
room I think if you polled everybody
that probably say yes as we sit here
right now even coming off of a huge win
against the Rams but this story hasn't
been written yet and but I do think that
he's going to have to at least get to
the NFC championship game for him to
keep his job you're on record I think
last week is saying that you'd like to
maybe explore job in the front
is for a team we were wondering do you
have a resume printed out like did you
go to Kinkos or you just take pictures
of your Super Bowl rings like I'm gonna
have to see a little bit more Troy yeah
no I think most people would you know I
mean I don't know what John Lynch's
resume was either but but you know I do
to say do I want to be I guess you could
say and I'm reluctant to even have that
discussion and I have been over the
years because manat there's probably not
any former players that wouldn't say oh
yeah you know I'd like to work in the
front office some some time and and yet
I went into this TV route role and and
it's been great for me as a single
father for many years and raising my
girls and it afforded me an opportunity
to be able to do that and I knew that at
some point now I've got a junior and a
senior in high school and and so the
opportunity potentially can be there I'm
53 years old I'm not I'm not naive you
know I I laugh at your question about a
resume I don't I take that very
seriously because I also understand that
I haven't been working in a front office
for the last 20 plus years and so there
would there would be a learning curve so
to speak well the opportunity ever
present itself probably not and and if
it were to come up would I actually take
the job I don't know you know depend on
where it is who it's with and there's a
lot of factors that go into that but it
is a job that I think I'd be very good
at and I think that if my time comes and
goes and I never got the opportunity to
do that I think I'd always sit there in
question as to whether or not I I could
have done the job so that's kind of word
and it's not me being naive and saying
oh yeah you know hand it over to me and
let me show you how it start it's
nothing like that I think it's it's me
it's it's it's not ego it's just haven't
been in a locker room having been on
championship teams having traveled the
league for the last 20 years in
broadcasting and been around some really
great minds and great organizations I
think it'd be interesting for me to see
if it's something that I couldn't
conquer but you made some headlines
saying you probably wouldn't do it with
the Cowboys is that being fair to
paraphrase you that if you had that
opportunity
said is that it's it's it's most
unlikely that it would ever have Sun
likely it would happen anywhere but it's
most unlikely that it would happen here
in Dallas just because of the the
structure of the organization and of
course Jerry being the owner general
manager and and and his sons being
involved it's just I I think that things
are kind of in place as to as to how
that's going to be and it's been that
way for for a long long time so I don't
think not only myself I don't think I
don't think gee this is not a criticism
I just don't think Jerry Jones will
bring anybody in that would serve in a
capacity such as one that I would prefer
I think the media probably wanted to
look at this is you you taken a shot at
Jerry know I know the Cowboys very well
and obviously and the structure of it as
I said has not changed and since I was
playing so when I look at the Cowboys
and I say boy is there a team that I
feel that I could help I guess the
Cowboys would be the team that I feel
that I could help the most because it's
a team that I know the most in and and I
know how things are done and I know how
things might be able to be improved I go
back to I think I met you when I talked
to you at Joe Buck's golf tournament
celebrity golf tournament you I don't
even think you had done a game yet and I
remember and we were sitting in a
conference room and I was doing an
interview and I remember saying can you
be honest like that's the hard thing for
players because they want to play nice
I mentioned this I think it was two
weeks ago I brought it up you've
mastered it like you got to the point
where I don't think you've ever been
better it feels like maybe it's that
point where as a quarterback you kind of
feel like okay I understand this I got
confidence here but I've heard a
different you this year for some reason
than I have in previous years is there
anything different you know it's I've
heard that from a few other people and I
haven't felt I haven't felt that I've
been more opinionated I haven't felt
that I've been more honest maybe
situations have come up that have given
me an opportunity to to say some things
that that people then you know maybe a
resonator or struck people a little bit
differently I don't know I do know this
that and I do remember the
dan was at J bucks and it was where I'd
ever done a broadcast and my first press
conference when they paired Joe Buck and
Cris Collinsworth and I together
I was asked hey can you be critical and
I thought wow I mean I don't know that
that's my job to be critical my jobs to
be honest and if criticism is what's
required then I have the obligation to
do that but I think there's a notion
amongst the media that that as an
analyst you just have to be critical and
they want to hear you bash on the
coaches or the players and I have great
respect for those people I know how hard
this game is but I think as I've gotten
further removed from the game I still
maintain a healthy respect for all of
those involved but maybe it's social
media maybe it's just that you know I'm
kind of you kind of get hardened a
little bit I guess for lack of a better
word and in in the criticisms of your
own I mean I'm not if I'm critical of a
call or a play or something of that
nature you know I get it just as much on
the other end myself you you know that
as well and I think maybe you just kind
of say hey what's you know just be as
honest as you can and be fair and that's
how I've tried to go about doing it
really throughout my career but I've had
a number of other people say the same
thing is what you just asked and it kind
of gave you a big compliment there you
didn't really pay it back so it's a
little I'll take a try well thanks
appreciate your time tell Julie that's a
tear Oy Aikman hall-of-famer a
three-time Super Bowl champion for more
Dan Patrick show tune in the audience
channel 239 on DirecTV stream for free
on BR live or download the Dan Patrick
show app
[Music]